from new york city the city's so nice
they named it twice in fact we have two
games against the yankees this brief
two-game series comes to a close tonight
as atlanta tries to knock off masahiro
tanaka oscar inoue is the man on the
mound for atlanta with a big off day
coming for the greatest tomorrow
masahiro tanaka is going to be making
his 166th
career major league start
he's been good in the boogie down too so
he's going to tow that slab again
there's travis dorno
swings at the first pitch and hits it
deep to center field hicks back he's on
the track near the wall leaps and he
makes the play
took an extra base hit away from darneau
as swanson heads back to first
off the bat you think it had a chance
that's a home run he doesn't make that
catch that's over the wall
so hicks just saved two runs on that
play here is ozuno at a long three run
home run last night swing and a miss
ozuna down on strikes no run to hit no
errors in one man left
oscar inoue is the man who's charged to
give the braves innings and hold these
yankees down and hope the braves bats
come alive early well that's going to
bring up luke voight with a long
three-run home run in the first inning
yesterday
oh nice
lined over the leaping try of riley and
down into the left field corner goes to
the wall and voight
has himself a double as johan camargo
stands in marche is
a lead at first on a 1-2 pitch
and camargo drives that ball deep to
right of its fare it's long gone it is
and atlanta jumps in front two-nothing
on a two-run homer from johann camargo
and he admired that baby
sanchez will start it off
that one's drilled deep to left field
going back duvall track wall see ya a
home run for sanchez and the yankees are
on the board second home run of the year
for gary sanchez
right into the fire for clint frazier in
right field the need is real his judge
is out of the lineup
high fly ball deep left center duvall
back he's on the track he's at the wall
sia
frazier goes downtown and it's a 2-2
game
what a way to start right when you come
from that alternative side little red
thunder for you coney welcome back man
so here's dansby
swanson
chop toward third charging urshella
a nice stretch and scoop by voight and
that will do it in the fourth
all right so dj lemay will start off the
bottom of the fourth inning he has a hit
so he's do another one to get his
seemingly daily multi-hit game
and if you have enough average hitters
and power
hey you know what michael how about
another line drive to right field as we
speak about his hitting another
multi-hit game hicks has walked in
flight out there's the 02 to hicks
swung on and drilled to deep left center
inciardi on the run and he can't make
the catch it bangs off the left center
field wall lemayo heads around third
he's coming home the relay throw is
going to be
not in time he just dove in safely see a
good kind of trick slide slide away from
the catcher and sneak your hand in there
clearly safe here's gleber torres
now in his line in the right center
field it is a base hit
hicks will score easily it's an rbi
single for torres and it's 4-2 yankees
anxious to see this guy step to the
plate he's had two tremendous at-bats
home running a
single lying down the left field line it
is a base hit it's going to go to the
corner what an impressive
game for clint frazier who's been
waiting for the opportunity and he's
three for three no two way here is le
mayhew
that one is looped into right field it's
going to dunk in for a base hit
scoring easily is frazier it's an rbi
single for lemay who ho-hum has three
more hits and the yankees lead 5-2
here is voight that one is lined in the
center field that is a base hit lemayo
will score easily
and the ball gets away from inciarte
going to second is voight and he is safe
dj lemay who has three hits tonight and
forward bats
that one's driven out to deep right
center field and sierte back on the
track at the wall he's going to play it
off the wall and gets by him lamey
around second he's going for third and
sierte falls down and lemayo will make
it with a triple four hits today
for the machine boy is he living up to
his nickname so it comes down to britain
and duvall
this should do it ground ball
boyt steps on the bag and the yankees
sweep the braves they win this one by a
score of 6-3